it took me a long time
yes
can you hear me yet yeah all right
sorry
i put that motion
all those in favor please say hi against
the motion is carried thank you
councillors
uh is there any urgent late business
needing to be discussed this afternoon
does not i'll put the motion um
we'll move on then
and we move on now to item five and
pages 10 through to 42
proposed fees and charges for 20 22 23
and
who's going to lead this discussion
jamie
the floor is yours
thank you your worship
uh so further to the workshops that we
did
in reviewing
the
budget part of that is in fact the fees
and charges as part of council's income
and so what i have done what the team
have done we have met with
a lot of the managers all the managers
basically to discuss
the fees many of them have remained
unchanged and those that have changed we
have reasons for
which are detailed in there i've also
highlighted them in yellow
some of the main drivers for that would
certainly be in the cemeteries and the
building control space where what we're
also trying to maintain is the revenue
and financing policy percentages of what
income comes from rates and what income
comes from fees and charges um and the
one i point out is that the cemeteries
actually was slightly skewed in favor of
rates um due to the
income from fees being done
so i know i'd just like to thank the
managers for the work and investigation
that they did looking at comparative
fees for other councils in the lower
south island
thank you jamie
okay um
who's going to open this it's open for
discussion now
council heisted thank you
you thank you i have a question around
the green waste
um charges and i realize we uh it's part
of the um
the minutes of the last meeting um on
page eight those minutes refer to
um if i can just get back there bear
with me um charges being over the 100 kg
threshold be charged at 120
i'm just not clear on the fees and
charges
whether the
fee kicks in
at 101 kgs back to zero or whether it's
100 kgs
at zero
thereafter
so we could get some clarification on
that
i'm not clear
jamie do you want to
give something
the um
fees that were adopted in the previous
meeting
um basically a green waste load of less
than 100 kilos is free but if you come
in with greater than 100 kilos then you
were paying 12 cents per kilo on the
entire load
so that means that 120 kilos would be
120 times
12 cents
so is that what we intended as council
well i'm not clear it wasn't my
understanding and i think the wording of
over the 100k threshold is
is perhaps misleading
i think we would have some disappointed
users who came at 101 kgs and we've
charged
12 and 12 cents
but
i don't know that's just i'd be
interested in the other councillor's
recollection of what we were in fact
agreeing to the report
does suggest what the staff are saying
but i don't know if that was the
intention of the motion
yeah certainly my my understanding was
that it would commence
it once you got over the 100 kilos but
um open for discussion
any other thoughts around the table on
this particular issue
sir
councillor grant and council
thank you worship i agree with
councillor heisted i believe that should
be
it should start at a hundred dollars it
shouldn't be a hundred dollars and mean
so
i'm sorry 100 kilos
i think that was the intention of the
meeting
councilman
foul
just through your worship you know i
think um
just
in recalling how we discuss that i
believe that we were looking at that
100 kilo threshold and then
obviously charging from that point there
the only thing would be the um
the operational side of it trying to
work out
weights i'm not sure that's going to
cause a problem
but i agree they shouldn't be charged
back charged through back to that
zero point
so is there anybody able to comment on
the operational side of things in terms
of how that would happen at the
at the tip face for one of a bit of work
you worship i'll venture a guess but i
don't think it would be a problem
because um
at present all green waste is weighed
anyway so even though it might be free
it's being recorded for tonnage so that
shouldn't be a problem the only thing i
would um suggest you worship
is if the council was minded to
go with the
um the first hundred kgs being free
which is established and then the meter
cuts in from the 100 kgs further north
the council staff may want to just
revisit
the financial impact of that in terms of
whether it's going to create the type of
level of revenue uh anticipated for what
is at the moment
an account or an activity that
isn't deficit
so that may be something the council may
want us to
to look at
and as a way forward worship maybe we
can
park the implementation of the greenways
fee bear in mind at the moment given the
weather there's probably not a lot not a
lot of call on the services
and that we come back to you with a
report just highlighting what the impact
would be
before you made a final decision
okay thoughts around the table
sounds like a sensible
way forward to me
you think you worship i i believe that's
probably what we need to do because we
haven't had a report about matera and
that was going to be on the agenda as
well so right
we should do that as well i think okay
thank you
so thank you council heisted for raising
that any other issues with fees and
charges
need to be talked about now
just on the consent side are we covering
our costs now that we've moved more to a
consultant base
um we haven't changed changed our
charges at all
can you comment on that
yes through you mr mr worship um
the
there is a line in air fees and charges
that does say that consultants costs
will be recovered so there is there's
actually a line there so we are
recovering the costs of air of of the
consultants we're using
thank you
other issues
council reid
perfect
thank you you worship um just looking at
the library um as we've got here adult
fiction first two years no charge
does that incorporate the charge for
the 50 cent
of the new fiction
because i think normally when you go to
the library and pick up a piece of new
fiction it's a 50 cent charge and i
don't see anything about that there
okay can
anybody help us with that one
see some puzzled looks
you worship and certainly the intention
was to retain
uh charges in the library um and that
way i know that was the resolution of
the council
so
um
that if that's not included it should be
because
i know that
the district librarian was keen to see
fees and charges
removed
but this council had a deliberate policy
of keeping them in play and that
certainly was the attention of staff so
it may just be of a slighter mission out
on our part
just just further today uh your worship
on page
31 out of 109 or page 29
that is covered off under the reserves
adults at 50 cents
so so it is the same there is last year
but that's not a new book
it's you know like new fiction is
charged at 50 not reserving a book when
you reserve something you're waiting to
get it
sorry but i'm quite happy for that to be
looked at and
an answer come back okay thank you so
then it sounds like the intention was to
re retain that fee in there
okay
council heisted
yeah thanks tracy um just a question
three eta to russell building consent
fees you mentioned that you review the
charges aligned to neighboring councils
and this is a first increment so
where does gorgeous councils sit with
these new fees and charges
compared to our neighbours are we still
under or are we
on a path
um
okay um
so
any other issues councils would like to
see here before we move to resolution
so would somebody like to move that the
fees and charges
for the year ending first of july be
adopted with um note the two previous
issues items that we've talked about one
the library
and
solid waste uh yeah library
okay thank you council davis secretary
councillor grant thank you
all those in favor
against the motions carried thank you
councillors
all right that brings us on to the
adoption of the annual plan for 22 23
and my understanding there is there is
some change there so perhaps
steve or nay do you want to talk us
through this one
yes thank you your worship
um
late yesterday
we identified an anomaly with the model
and we worked tirelessly to get these
figures corrected into you today
overall what the overall impact is is
very very little so
we are still looking at 5.94 average
increase across the district and an
unbalanced budget of
763 000 as opposed to the 1.25 million
that is
in my report
now the impact of the change changes
where the impact hits most is the
distribution between the various um
rating areas so the average the average
rating increase for rural is now 4.78
and for urban is 6.42
now and in particular um commercial is
being hit hard um for in in the new
regime and it's all around our revenue
and financing policy with the decisions
that council has made at the workshop we
had around the roading and putting the
20 increase in inflation on roading that
has had an impact on the urban and
commercial users
and the other part of the revenue
financing policy that we have is that we
restrict and heavy industry to the
average increase
so the increase in roading has caused a
bigger than increase
in
urban and commercial
and that hasn't been offset by in the
heavy industry as it normally would
um
so yes but it
overall west
the team is still fairly happy with
where we where we're at compared to what
the inflation rate is at six point nine
percent um to get an increase of only
5.94 is
as commendable happy to take some
questions
so i um i understand that this is a
surprise for councillors is a surprise
for for me as as well and i'm sure for
the chief executive so it is something
that's just popped up at the very much
last minute but um i guess that really
brings us to the point
do we want to carry on and confirm our
annual plan today or do we want some
time to further consider it but i'll be
interested in your views steve as chief
executive on this particular issue
thank you worship yeah like it was a a
surprise but as lornae is summarized
the
the overall result is still the same
it's just the instance of racing that is
hitting different sectors now that the
model has been
righted
i guess what i would say is this
highlights the deficiencies in our
current rating system and why we need to
critically overhaul it
and in previous workshops we've seen
some of the perverse outcomes that come
from our system which has been
fine-tuned and tampered with over the
years to try and smooth out the instance
of rating
but in the end result is that
there are some
quirks in the system that
generate some unexpected outcomes and
the heavy industrial rating area is one
of those which was established 18 19
years ago in response to a council
funding review
but since that time we've seen
industries
well the biggest industry this is this
district has seen 50 years and matera
valley milk for example uh isn't in that
particular rating island because the
heavy rating industry
or rating island is called
is only in matara
and it was designed to fix a certain
problem of of that error
so in the current ltp we are committed
to conducting a comprehensive review of
our rating system
including some of the sacred tablets
that have
guided this council for the last 30
years so that's the likes of whether we
should have one rating area
as opposed to an effect three rating
errors
so there's not much we can do to save
the current result because your revenue
and financing policy is something you do
every three years you review it you set
it
and to amend it takes a bit of time
because you have to go through a special
consultative procedure
and some would say that once you've put
a place a policy
you must have the faith and the
principles of that policy and let the
rating
results flow there from
so in a nutshell you worship
in terms of making a decision this
afternoon
you're perfectly entitled to defer it
and to do so would not
jeopardize any statutory obligation
because we've got to the end of june
and but in terms of trying to find
a better result of raising incidents i
don't believe you've got a the time
and b it's a proper course of action to
go through when you've just reviewed
that policy through last year's ltp
thank you steve
okay
so counselors i'm i'm just interested in
your your thoughts on this one at the
moment
both in
the way forward and
and where we go from here yeah
council davis
do you have any examples of what the
commercial area can expect as a rate
increase for them
we have
lorna
yes thank you your worship um they are
included in the new document on page
on page 57 so what we have is examples
um the gold commercial depending on the
capital value the increases range from
5.13 to 12.88
and in the mathilda commercial they
range from 5.74 up to 25.69
councillor bulger
um
question for steve so
to adjust this we'd have to adjust our
funding policy
which we have to consult on and
so basically we don't have
that time
we can identify the problem but we
actually don't have the tools to do
anything about it or the or the time to
do anything about them
you're right
you're right
okay uh council grant
say you worship uh lorna
you've sent us a document at three
o'clock today
for this which is um
um you know as you suggested it was
extremely late and um yeah we
acknowledge
uh you
found a mistake in there somewhere
so reading into this has anyone
everybody seen this document it's
actually on your email yes it didn't
come through on the hub it's sitting in
your email so i think it's on the hub
now is it on the hub now
we i believe uh on your email you've got
we should be uh we've got two options we
either adopted today or we we hold off i
believe we should hold off
um and give us time to have a look at
this or unless you want to go blow by
blow through this here now but um
getting my head around it does that mean
on your
rates resolution recommendation and if
we flick down to
commercial capital value per rating
does that mean uh if you uh uh if your
commercial capital rate is 0 to 98
thousand you're paying an extra five
hundred and ten dollars is that right
is that extra or is that what the rate
is
that is the parks and reserves targeted
rate right okay so
yeah it's going to take a little bit of
time for a few of us to get our heads
around this so i would i would sooner
i hear your comments steve but i would
sooner um
we defer this for um it only may be a
week
extraordinary council meeting to put it
through because we do need to get our
heads around it we need to have a look
at it and uh it's unfair to to
i know the problem was but we can't you
can't get a document dropped on you at
three o'clock and a half or seven
yeah i understand exactly where you're
coming from uh councillor grant
um
i i guess
we do have that choice before us i think
councillor bulger sort of summed it up
before
you know we we may take a little bit of
time
um and that's right and proper that we
do if we choose to do that actually
we're not going to be able to make any
changes
at this point in time in the process i
don't think
um so
you know
it's it's one way or the other
yeah
any other thoughts from councillors
council house did you look as though
you're going to say something
thank you your worship um
look i i hear what doug is saying but i
think councillor bulger and the chief
executive summed it up this isn't this
isn't what we deliberated on our
workshops um we actually work really
hard to reduce
a rate increase that was coming in at 15
and above
um down to the 6.9 sorry down to the
5.94
we probably haven't told that story like
it's not just about today it's about a
serious workshops and uh and working
with the staff so
um
we do have a five percent um rate cap we
are over that but we are running
inflation at six point nine percent and
that's what our workshop was about we
don't have the ability to effect change
in this policy
in the time we have and we didn't
actually turn our minds to that because
policy was fixed and we see that policy
a number of years ago so while it would
be great to pause and uh
and have a think about it we're going to
come back and make the same decision
yes so
you're just just on the point you make
there brett i i appreciate that
we didn't set it well we said it a few
years ago but we reviewed it through the
ltp process quite recently so
so it is something we have looked at
and
any other counselors uh council phillips
thank you worship yeah well i'm
extremely disappointed with the the
right increase for
i know it's just a timing thing you know
we the district planning committee have
been working really hard to try and
to get that changed and and i think um
it's just a timing thing
for for some of that um
industrial land that we're trying to
change over especially for brick street
and matera
so once that changes over i think
hopefully we'll get a bit of
a bit of relief for some of them
but anyway
okay councillors um i'm in your hands um
counselor garden
yeah i've had quite a few questions on
the old plan now this is all changed i
think i need time to read it
and um
crunchy numbers for the last couple days
and then all of a sudden it's all
changed
okay counselor davis saying
right um your worship i think given that
we've just been given this information
today it would be prudent
for us to have a look at it
um we wouldn't be doing
justice to it if we didn't so i think we
need to look at it
and come back with whatever questions we
have
get those answers satisfactorily before
this progresses
thank you
okay so um
are you moving that way councillor davis
well i can do but it depends on the time
frame so we have to put a time on it so
so we're open to suggestions
maybe a week's time
council is comfortable with a weak time
counselor um
grant you're comfortable with that uh
yes i will be i probably won't be at the
meeting though
but yeah i can zoom in
okay so
oh you're you're moving at councillor
davis you're seconding it counselor yeah
thanks
okay so my understanding is that the
motion is that um we pause the
discussion on the annual plan process
for one week from today
and reconvene to
discuss
some of the changes that have occurred
in the last 24 hours
okay so let's open for discussion
any discussion i'll put that emotional
lies in favor please say aye
against
the motion is carried thank you
councillors
and
look and i just want to say thank you
lornae i know it's pretty unfortunate
position you find yourselves in um but i
do know that there's been a hang of a
lot of effort going behind the scenes so
um i look forward to having that further
discussion with you in a week's time
right so
we will move on then to item eight
and which is the youth council but youth
council is going to be here about
five o'clock i understand so we might
just
push that one back a little bit
and
item nine
issuing of warrants and authorization
um
so um
we need to have some um some new
warrants issued and we have a memo here
from governance manager
with regard to that do you have anything
to say susan
it's just it's a standard process
okay
any counselor has got any questions
about item
nine
okay moved councillor bulger secondary
councillor mctinnell
all those in favor please say i
against the motion is carried
right
review of the gore district council
keeping of animals poultry and bees
bylaw hearing
and we have a report of the hearing
and um two recommendations
it's open for discussion and all
movement of those
recommendations
counselor dixon thank you worship um i
was just going to say that we just had
that one submission and it was about um
dogs so it wasn't relevant
to this but um i think submitters made a
very good point and we should be
considering their submission when we
when we review the
dog's
policy
councillor heisted
you just a question to the committee
were there any significant changes to
the old bylaw
no there was none
okay would somebody like to move the
recommendations
move council dixon's secondary
councillor mctinnell
no further discussion all those in favor
please say aye against the motion is
carried thank you councillors
uh we'll move on then to item 11 which
is the rural travel fund
and we have a set of minutes
and a recommendation that they be
noted and received
somebody like to move along those lines
council make to now do i have a seconder
for that
councilor reed thank you all those in
favor please say aye okay motion is
carried thank you
item 12 um council
policy worship was there any
did you open that for discussion
uh very quickly yeah
i must have missed it can i discuss
gotta be quick
yes you can is it too much um
just to query i support southland
i support south and make up three
identities there's uh i believe there's
the
hockey
and then there's the curving and then
there's the ice skating figure
so i spy sports southland has a applied
requested twice i mean uh i've got no
issue with the recommendations i'm just
wondering which part of my sports
cellphone was asking for what
so
when that sort of thing happens because
i support south when there's recently
there have been a few upheavals around
the road and
it's just
a good idea to figure out who's asking
for what and what's doing who and
um
yeah good good point um council grant
and we identify it with the other
organizations
while there might be multiple uh funding
applications from an organisation that
are identified into the area
i don't see any issue of um
making sure that in future we do
separate those
it's just well i mean for instance some
peters have
applied
three times a year and they've got
hockey network rugby
and ghoul has done the same so
you know
it was just a thought i had looking at
it thinking well which part of i saw
south was actually asking for that oh
look i
it wasn't part of the discussion so i
don't know i can't tell you um can
anyone enlighten me
sorry i can't remember that there would
have been two separate entities within
it that they just had right so one was
one and one was the other yeah okay so
it might be just recording yeah okay so
um susan did you have some information
okay
okay
thank you
in worship there is four four
organizations within nice sports housing
four yeah speed skating all right
you're part of that
yesterday
okay
we'll move on then to um
item 12 uh council vehicle policy
and we have a report from the chief
executive do you want to talk us through
this steve
yeah thanks your worship um this is uh
an endeavor to
review our policy settings on a number
of topics this current year and so a
couple of months ago you looked at the
and reviewed and approved the
disposal land and buildings policy
this and there are some other policies
that are coming before the ordinance
committee and will ultimately win their
way to the full council
during the next three months or so so
this is really just a modernization of
our policy
one thing and i'll explain some of the
features in the covering report about
where we've
placed a greater emphasis on vehicle
driver responsibility and safety
just please note the appendix in the
reviewed policy
shouldn't be there so the appendix one
that was intention was to delete that
because now we got a software safe 365
application which
if there is an accident all staff are
directed to actually input the details
of the accident online so rather than
the manual form so it was the intention
to actually have this particular
appendacy removed from the new policy
apart from that worship happy to take
any tissues okay
so with that note
any questions or comments on the
vehicle policy
if not would somebody like to move the
recommendation
please
determined yes sublime to that change
council hosted job seekender for that
councilman thank you
any further discussion
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
right um
item 13
groundswell new zealand and three waters
reform and we have quite a foursome
report
from the chief executive responding to a
request
from groundswell
uh also
includes
the letters that we've already sent to
both
the prime minister and the minister of
the local government with regard to the
issues that that have been raised but
i'll let you talk us through it steve
and we'll go from there
you think she worship um
grantswell have written to all councils
in new zealand
and sought
clarification about how each council has
voted
and
also
suggested that's how they voted on the
reforms
um and what resolutions were um
that were passed by the each council and
wanted to know obviously not obviously
but they wanted to know
how each individual elected member voted
i was able to reply by saying this
council has
passed a resolution in september last
year
and opposed the reform process as it was
then
presented to the
uh councils for consideration
and that you that resolution was passed
unanimously
and i think it
needs to be born in mind that i know
there's been some
public meetings being held and and
elected members have been asked to
declare their hand
but this council has been quite
consistent in its opposition to three
waters reform uh it has laid down the
gauntlet to the government and said it
prefers a
a true funding partnership that's
for a very important
part of infrastructure new zealand akin
to what happens with roading
but unfortunately two things have
happened
one is that the government changed its
stance from you can either opt-in or
opt-out to declaring that the whole
process would be mandatory
and that occurred after the submissions
were
put to the minister of local government
at the end of september last year
so that changed the the ball game from
one of uh being able to
uh determine our own fate to one of
being this is the way it's going to be
um
and so
that really
means that you can't um
it's hard to
conduct a referendum
uh on something where you don't have the
control of being able to answer the
people's views
and act in a way which that may be in
accordance with those views
secondly of course the council's idea of
a funding partnership was just simply
rejected it's it's been
as a worship and i've been to a number
of meetings where that's been canvassed
before government officials
and they've repeatedly said it's not on
the table for discussion disappointing
but that's the way
the um
the powers that be have
told the council this is this is what
it's going to be so it places the
council in an invidious position of um
having to live with a reform agenda
having its ideas rejected
but also being responsible to
respect the government of the day that
is democratically elected and if
legislation does
find its way through becoming law
then the council will be duty-bound to
follow that
whether a referendum should be held is
completely a matter for the council i
would venture to suggest however you
worship but if a referendum was going to
be held
it seems to me that it would be better
replaced to be a national one because
ultimately the question
and the background information should be
the same for whether you're a voter in
nagor district or whether you're in the
far north or somewhere in between
so that's something that's worth perhaps
contemplating
from the powers that be and some may say
that the ultimate referendum lies in the
next year's general election where the
government of the day will be determined
by everyone in the nation
and finally worship the issue of
withdrawal of lgbt funding as i
explained in my report lgnz is in the
position of trying to represent all
councils some of whom have quite
different views on this matter
one never knows
how much traction eligine may have got
in private meetings with the government
where the government has i think to be
fair
had a pretty steadfast view on
the need for reform in three waters
and hasn't shown itself to be too
inclined to change his mind apart from
alterations to the basic model
but the tenant of
four ward entities uh governing and
managing and delivering three waters has
been
out there in front of local government
championed by the central government for
now
well over 12 months
should lgnz be penalised for
trying to do its best in a very troubled
and
difficult sector
not not sure i mean but
from a gdc point of view we don't have
any policy people we rely on lg nz to do
a lot of things for us and it's not just
in three waters it's in
um
the anything to do with rating to do
with solid waste climate change uh the
rma reforms they're all there
and elgin's heads in in the on our
behalf on the sector's behalf trying to
influence government thinking so i think
it behooves the council to just
take on a wider view and tread
carefully
before it comes to a decision to sever
its ties with lgnz and withdraw funding
and i dare say ultimately membership
it's a big step to take it's certainly
one within the council's power to do
but i think
almost natural justice would perhaps
dictate that
lgnz be given the chance to defend
itself before it's condemned
thanks
steve and and i agree with all the
comments that that you've made um
with perhaps one slight exception when
you talked about this um this council
being opposed to
three waters reform
uh i believe we're as opposed to the
model
not
the need for the three waters reform and
and i know i've had a number of
discussions with
a number of people including quite a few
from from groundswell and in recent days
and
i don't believe they really understand
the true nature of the state the parlia
state of our water infrastructure not
just here but up and down the country
and the need for reform
we have been objecting to the model
we've put up an alternative model and i
know a number of other councils were
were reasonably um
keen to to follow that model as well but
the government for whatever reason
they've said no that's not going to work
so i i think the
the the points that steve's made about
where we find ourselves now and where
we have a choice to make or we we have
to answer to groundswell anyway the
questions have asked around our
involvement with lg and zed and and also
a referendum are ones that we need to
address now but we
from my experience with lgnz
they've done incredibly good work
on on a whole host of fronts not just
water reform and
whether they've done the right thing
there or not they'll be judged by by
their actions by the membership and you
know that could come sooner rather than
later but
with regard to to
referendum i really can't understand
what a referendum would gain
and indeed what you'd even ask
actually
for people to vote on
because you're when you ask people to
vote on a referendum you're
assuming that they have a good
understanding of the issue before them
in fact it's
it's critical that they do have a good
understanding and and i really don't
believe there's been
as much education or information
uh
as possibly should be out there for
people to pick up i guess
if they search for it it is there
and it's there in volumes
um but it's it's not
as simple as it it might be to um to
gain that information
anyway the um the item is open for
discussion and i'll be interested in
counsellors views
councillor
belgium then council dixon
um
your worship uh and chief executive i i
think you've
explained the situation very well
so i'm i'm only going to reiterate
or put your points
you know in the in my own
peculiar all my my own way
um
i can't see the sense in um
resigning or departing from ltnz that
that will achieve nothing
we'd be throwing the baby out with the
bath water
we've already tried to negotiate with
central government by sending a letter
to
the minister of local government and the
prime minister saying that we do not
we're not comfortable with the model as
it proposed we got nowhere
and so we need a larger organization and
the combined mic if you like
of other councils as we join together in
the ltnz so i certainly wouldn't support
um resigning from ltz nz i think it
would be a mistake
and it would serve no purpose
uh holding a referendum on on three
waters policy i'll repeat again
some months ago before we've even been
approached by groundswell
we voiced their displeasure at the model
as proposed by central government we're
not comfortable with it we
as you rightly said we recognize
the need for
investment and infrastructure the right
power can't afford it we need taxpayer
government input
we are not happy with the model
we've expressed that in letter we don't
want to lose control and we want to have
local representation and we believe the
people
locally can do the work
and
you know a demonstration of that in
their
long term or
annual plan is a commitment to upgrading
in their finance financial commitment to
retaining control
a referendum let's assume for a moment
that a
referendum was held
and
the majority of people wanted us to
oppose
three waters reform
let's assume that let's assume that
nobody wants the three waters reform
where does that leave us that leaves us
exactly where we are now with a central
government who said they are going to
mandate the reform and we have no choice
there is only one thing that i and and i
would encourage um
groundswell and their supporters to to
to do and that's to tackle a change in
government
you know
we've had another party said that they
will
uh
repeal it and rework it now i don't i
don't know what that means but maybe the
question should be asked for
other major parties who aren't presently
in government
what that repeal and place would be
because we've got a clear indication
from the labor lead government that they
are removable and not going to listen to
anybody
i'm not happy with it i know
nobody in the local government's happy
with it and i don't think anybody around
the table is happy with it
but that's where we find ourselves thank
you
and i'd agree with the council's stance
that we
we've done all we can but there's
interesting groundswell should be
actually targeting those councils that
have large rule schemes and irrigation
schemes and trying to push for them to
be outside three waters
and i think our neighbours the clutha
and south and they're both in that
category
we have been lucky that a time water
scheme have done it on their own accord
and the outro grammaker and the
co-wearer schemes have both gone out
privately in the past
and they've separated themselves from
the three waters
now the three waters is for three waters
water for human consumption storm water
and sewage
the rural schemes were set up for stock
water as main as a main source and for
irrigation and in the meantime people
have connected to them
and they're going to get captured in
this three waters
overtake and those most of those scams
were funded by the farmers and with the
subsidy from government and the councils
ran them
and as we saw the talmud scheme went to
court i went to the for a bill of
parliament to get out
now there's a small window
uh with brian and the clutha council
that he's trying to push that will allow
rule schemes to get out and that needs
to be pushed by groundswell
yeah and that's exactly what lgnz
working party are pushing as well so
yeah um i think there's some some gains
to be made by
uh local cup in new zealand and
groundswell working together actually
rather than try and separate everybody
off from from lgnz they should be
looking to see how they can do it
collectively
the other question would be is with the
lg nz if you removed yourself from the
lg nz does that remove yourself
the ability to borrow from the local
government agency i don't believe so i
think that's a separate well the local
government funding agency is a separate
organization altogether it came about
through the good efforts of algenzetto
so
there has been some good stuff happen
along the way and continues to happen uh
outside of the three waters so
yeah again you know the term baby in
water does come to mind when you talk
about exiting lgnz
council dixon
thank you worship
um my question is is did local
government new zealand have the mandate
to sign
heads of agreement with the government
saying that they wouldn't oppose the
three waters proposal because the the
detail wasn't
intelligible then and i just think that
did did gorgeous council
actually give that so the
yeah that like the local government uh
local government new zealand is a
membership organisation
and uh it's governed by a board
and there's representatives from across
the country you know i had the good
fortune of sitting on that board for
about nine years i'm not there now
fortunately
um but they make decisions all the time
on behalf of what they think is the the
best interests of of local government
across the whole of the country so i
they do have that mandate as an
organisation they don't have a mandate
from us to do it because they didn't ask
us
but
there are a lot of questions being asked
or a lot of questions being asked of
government and decisions made to work
with government on various things that
we don't know about either
thank you and i just think i do think it
would be quite reckless to pull out of
local government new zealand as there
are quite a number of benefits for good
district council but i would like to see
a strongly worded letter go to them just
reminding them that they represent the
local authorities and we're the voice of
our community as well
regarding the referendum i agree that it
should be a national referendum rather
than a local one and i also wonder how
the present government will be able to
borrow the billions required
without cross-party support because who
would lend to
to an entity that could be changed at
the next government
and the legislation would be
rescinded i think it's um
yes i think we need to
they need to show clearly that they can
continue with that legislation
so um
it's a bit of an aside i guess but um
itself will be at a local government uh
meeting tomorrow in wellington uh
tomorrow and friday
um
yeah tomorrow and friday uh when
thursday and friday in in wellington uh
and the minister of local government's
there and she'll be talking on this
subject and
you can be assured that they'll be
scrutinized
and questioned
absolutely thoroughly
councillor grant then councillor reed
thank you worship
editorial today in the southern times if
anyone hasn't seen it
the headline was pointless paired play
and one of the quote from there was the
playing factors that the parliament
gives local councils their functions and
powers and it has the authority to
remove them as well
we this is mandated from central
government
the three waters and
i
i back up what council bulger has said
also the question withholding funding
from local government new zealand
no
local government new zealand not only
just as as everybody has said
it's not all about three waters they do
do a lot of things behind the scenes and
so that's not part of it uh holding a
referendum here
uh been too late
i mean the referees are gonna if the
grounds swell i mean groundswell has got
every right to voice your opinion and
their opinion is is uh i believe as
councillor bulger says around the table
we all we all agree with them but
we're too late
so unless uh we have to tackle this as
uh whether you do it nationally or all
the councils combine through local
government new zealand voice your
opinion and we'll see how you go from
that but
in the last few days the the national
party is has led a bit of a campaign
against uh some ministers and some
appointed ministers of this of this
government and they have resigned and
she's changed them the leader of the or
the prime minister has changed those
appointments
so who used to say that uh pressure from
all local councils
uh
on
local government new zealand could do
some sort of change
it's worth crap
okay
thank you council grant councillor reed
sorry not very often i left the power to
speak
thank you um
as far as lgnz goes i'm
completely in the we should be staying
in the tent there is nothing you can
achieve when you're on the outside and
actually
given when you look at the number of
councils who have actually stepped out
of lgmz
it's a
not a massive amount
given the total but the one thing i
would like for the benefit of our local
ratepayers given the fact that there's
been a lot of
interest in
what groundswell's been saying locally i
would think it would just behove us for
the benefit of our ratepayers
to
go and publish in the ensign and on our
digital platforms the letter that
yourself
the mayor wrote to
minister mahuta and also to the prime
minister i think perhaps that would give
a little bit more clarity for some
people to realize that we have been
working behind the scenes and we have
our own opinion we had a an alternative
which is a good alternative given that
the government already supports us with
a 59
funding for roading through um waka
katauhi so yeah i just think we should
do that for the benefit of our local
rate payers
thank you council rude councillor
heisted
you thank you i think uh councillor
bulger summed it up well and i think
we're all at risk of probably repeating
ourselves uh but this table has been
pretty united uh in the view that's
that's been articulated um just reading
the groundswell letter i think it would
be important to clarify the concept that
we should not hand over assets
these assets are being taken
it's mandated as legislated we don't
have the opportunity to not hand them
over i would love to but we don't
on the local government nz front um none
of us here would be here without the
training from local government nz when
we first uh became councillors the
induction training
set us on the right path so there is a
far bigger picture but you're there
and i think the point around the
national referendum would be great if
this council gave that feedback um and
writing to groundswell that if they do
want to effect change um it's it's more
appropriately appointed at a national
level
thank you
thank you councillor uh heisted council
mcfarland
yep uh just three worship i won't rehash
everything again but um
obviously one of the things in regard to
the local government new zealand
is the information that's feeding back
to the mural forum and that we we need
some reassurance as councillors that our
leadership through the mural forums the
only information that we are
uh get as counselors is obviously
through media or all through the
newsletters and um
like your emails
and probably from
a ground point of view
i understand groundswell's very vocal
and has that role there but we're also
receiving it from the general and
average rate power person
they're not the only people that are out
there banging the tables stating that
there's issues and displeasure
about what's happening within the
reform and i think we need to make sure
we go back and get that reassurance that
from
the mayor uh if you're rubbing shoulders
with these people that we are
um putting that back up the road and it
is going to through the national level
uh i don't think we we um it would be
silly to be
removing ourselves and becoming
uh fragmented
because
in society today it seems to be a thing
to do when we get displeasure or we
don't agree with what's going on
suddenly we create our own band and then
move off and suddenly you have a number
of fragmented groups
achieving various causes
of different different nature
and the other thing is in regard to the
solutions obviously um
national referendum yes that would be
that would be great it would be good to
to voice that through i don't think we'd
achieve anything locally by having a
referendum you'd have a number of
different camps with another number of
different um
ideals or ideas coming through so
i probably sit the same united with
everyone else at the table and have some
faith in the fact that
leadership and mural leadership plus the
um
the local government have that avenue or
conduit to try and push it forward but
at the end of the day
agree this is mandated
we we're the dog with no teeth so
we've got some we've got some issues
thank you um councilman fowle
recalled a few things this week and
they've been called a dog with no teeth
before
um castle davis
thank you worship just on the
proposal that we put to
the local minister
um
to have a similar
uh structure that we have with waka
katahi have we pushed back on that
we received the letter and they said no
it's not an option that was it have we
actually
asked the other councils that agree with
us
and push back and asked why
and asked
can they please tell us the reasons why
they don't see that working because i
think
we haven't had that answer have we
not not really not
no not in detail so i think we should
push back and i think we should ask
those questions and just say the public
are
obviously very upset we've got a lot of
people in the community extremely upset
with the proposal people are not happy
and we need to be able to go back to
them with the reasons why
they can't see that actually proceeding
yep good good point
okay um any other counselors want to
make any comment at this point in time
councillor phillips
thank you restaurant
uh right at the start
when we first
heard about this that's going to come in
i and i was the only one that said
that we have to be very cautious
and be very
mindful of what's going to happen
and i see government will do what they
want to do regardless of what what we
might say
while we're down about 12 months down
the track now government have mandated
uh we've tried our best to
put forward what i would say was a
reasonably good proposal
uh and a good would come a good outcome
for small communities
and i see right at the start my concern
was about
how
the poor taxpayer will be
underdated with taxes to pay for this
and and that's still my concern
and um
and i think uh
we can only have a wait and see wait and
see
policy and i believe that um
it's only just started and i don't think
we're going to go go anywhere because
they've already decided what's going to
happen
okay councillors
any further comments like i think the
the
question that council davis has rose is
a good one and we do need to get a
little bit more clarity
in writing as to why the waka kitahi
model
won't fly in terms of
government acceptance
um so if the council grant
just a question on that your worship you
may not know or steve might know i don't
know um
has any other council in new zealand
proposed a waka katahi time of
funding as well or are we the only one
um certainly there's been quite a number
of councils talked about it just whether
they've formally adopted that or not i
don't know we'll need to find that one
out it would be interesting to see how
many actually
if anyone else adopted it i mean
instead of attacking it as a lone
council sitting down near the bottom of
the south island we might be able to
attack it with four or five of us so
hang on a minute we all we're all
reading off the same
sheet that's
uh can we have an answer please
yep no good point
okay so um
i guess we're at a point where we need
to get
a motion
from this discussion and
we have some recommendations there
and i guess
my take on what what i'm hearing is that
you know we receive and note the letter
um
we send the information to groundswell
that they request including the two
letters
um that have gone from this council to
government to date
and that
yeah
and that we considered
both
withdrawing withdrawing funding from
lgnz
and holding a referendum
but chose not to go any further on those
two matters at this point in time
is that what i'm hearing from around the
table
should be national uh and yeah and no no
we're not going to withdraw from lg okay
so um so how would you like that
well um
well i'll move that recommendation on
this report be received and that
we do not withdraw funding from local
government new zealand and we suggest
that
if
groundswell wants to
they try and
effect a national referendum on the
three waters before
would that work yep
that's fine do you want to be coming
you might like to say through your
worship that
given that the issue is the same
throughout the country
and in the interests of having the same
information
available and the same referendum
question
to every
voter in the country that if there is a
mood for referendum that should be
conducted on a national basis
i'll move what you just said
council dixon i was just wondering if we
could actually have little explanation
about why we
feel that we wouldn't want to withdraw
from local government new zealand as
well because of the benefits the other
benefits it's not just one
item we will write council will write to
groundswell and explain that but in
terms of emotion
um i think is there a seconder for that
councillor heisted
yeah i just think on the referendum we
should explain around that we should go
further to explain that we're not in a
position to effect change
you know that's why it needs to be done
at a national level
it should go to that next step okay
right it's getting altered a bit are we
keeping up
is there any
any other alterations that are required
to that
recommendation or that motion
it's been moved by councillor grant
davis segna for that councillor davis
thank you
uh if there's no further discussion i'll
put that motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
right
i'm just thinking i should use the card
that they were using at groundswell the
other day after after that
um
moves the car um
well just so happened i've got it here
on one side
on one side head there
and on the other side it hit there
i was in the red so i've been in the red
all my life
actually
okay um we'll move on thank you
councillors um we'll move on then to uh
item 14 which is a report that we get
from a
quarterly report we get from
dot loves data which gives us some
really good information on what's
happening in our communities
and i think that
well hopefully council has found this
quite informative
and it'll just be interesting to see how
the trends go
over the
over the next little period
but i'm open for any discussion any
comments counselors wish to make
on that one
just just wondered why i'm just
wondering why it just includes choir in
the rural area i think for all the
crimes
sorry
sorry i just didn't quite get the
question why why why people oh okay
mandeville seemed to be
missing so you worship that is correct
uh apparently waikaku must be crime free
that's right and he's a crime wave in
charlton
councillor reeve
i thought there was this is an excellent
um
report here there's actually quite a bit
of information that um probably as
locals we don't realize
interestingly enough while the crime
wave in waikaka is
zero in north gore it's obviously on the
way up so
and
the other one was
about the gambling in the area and
matera and has very low criminal
activity but it has a high gambling
problem
and that was my reading of the
statistics which was quite interesting
council grant
your worship would have been
at some stage would it be great to get
the
people that wrote this along just to
just to go through
uh the data and so we can all
certainly can yeah it would be really
good to because some of it is okay
you're looking at numbers and stuff but
if
we had uh the people that did this just
come on for five minutes and and tell us
exactly what what all of it is and we
then we know from then going forward
uh oh that's that and that's that it'll
be good
do that this is the first report we've
seen on this is that correct so it's
data does a whole lot of
this sort of thing um across a whole lot
of different sectors
um
it's an organisation that's the former
mayor of wellington
justin lester
was very involved in and i think he
still is
um so i know justin's down here from
time to time so it could be good to see
if we can get him along just to give us
a little bit of an information yeah if
we've got one of these reports uh in
front of us they'll be brilliant to uh
to for him to give us an in depth into
it and then once we've got it once
everyone knows what it's about it's good
you can just get into it and uh
we have access if there's anything
particular that is an issue for us that
we want to draw down on we can go to oh
is that right much greater detail as
well okay
councilman
i'd love to know how they got the
gambling spin per capita by ethnicity
and i think people who stay at the
poking machine actually poking their
initiative when they're playing it yeah
um
i guess
is that
yeah okay i don't know
i don't i don't know that one um be
interesting to ask that question council
read i don't have the answer for that
but the other thing i did note and i
think it's quite interesting is that
while the
number of transactions
and retail spending were down by nearly
10
the total value was up by 1.1
which begs the question some are
obviously missing out but that's
actually quite a substantial increase
given the times
yep so the trends are
you know they're telling telling a story
yeah
okay um
councillor phillips thank you worship
just for information that
the community board members and myself
last night had
visited with
cynthia fearley and the local policemen
in regards to some of the statistics
within our district um
and it would with cynthia's new job uh
will probably um be appropriate
you worship that maybe that uh as part
of that workshop that she'd be invited
and explained to her
maybe some of the counselors around the
table that what's happening in some of
her ideas and some of the things that
may be happening within within our
district that's quite surprising
actually
yep and i spoke to the new senior at
gore just recently and trying to work
out a time when um but he and others
come along to talk to council so he's
certainly on the agenda
okay uh would somebody like to move that
that be received
council reads secondary council make to
now all those in favor please say aye
against emotion is carried
um so that brings us to the end of the
open agenda with apart from one item
which is um youth council
and we have uh olivia and sophie uh
crawford who are here today just to
share a little bit about uh what's
happening in youth council so sophie and
olivia if you would like to come forward
and
let us know what's what's the go um
olivia is the the chair of the youth
council this year
might just need to speak up
um
i said we'll bring one over
thank you
awesome
okay
firstly i'd just like to make an apology
for laura heads as she wasn't able to
make it today
the goal youth council while not being
able to meet in person until yesterday
have had a fantastic start to the year
with some fantastic new councillors with
real drive who want to make things
happen
despite covert we have had a very
successful zoo we have had very
successful zoo meetings with mostly
everyone being able to attend
which has been awesome
each meeting we've been lucky enough to
have the privilege of having a guest
speaker thanks to mark who have helped
to open our minds to lots of avenues
that we were unaware of or didn't know
much about
back in march we had sonia guerkin and
jessica swann from the gore district
council to join us online and talk about
social media and events which was very
eye-opening
they had lots of innovative ideas and
were very keen to help us in the future
and the counselors also reciprocated
this keen attitude by asking lots of
questions
in april we had gemma o'neil from active
southland to talk about to talk to the
council
regarding a sports day that was
that was to be held in may but has been
postponed to later in the year
the council was asked
it was asked to give ideas as to what
the event might look like in terms of
what sports we could play etc
the idea of the event is to get school
kids moving and provide a safe
environment to learn some new skills
so we're excited to help make this event
happen later in the year
in may we were lucky enough to have the
mayor join us for our meeting and give
us ideas and tips on how to communicate
better within the council and how to
make the meetings more formal lots of
his tips were especially helpful to me
as chair and how i operate the meetings
and help with the flow of conversation
and we thank you again for your
attendance
we also had caitlyn wright join us later
in may to discuss social media and she
came with lots of good ideas like
creating an instagram page and being
more active on social media in general
so we can get the word out there about
what we're doing in and around the
community
overall even though we've only just met
in person yesterday we have hit the
ground running and it has been awesome
to have so many people come along to our
meetings and help and support us in many
ways
within the council we have made three
groups we have a communications group
which is led by laura hetz and allocates
sending out the zoom link or organizing
meetings when and where we are going to
have them each week
they organise who will be taking them
taking the minutes each meeting and
everyone is going to learn how to take
the minutes
and they are also in charge of ensuring
that someone does the enzyme report each
month making sure that it is a different
counsellor each week
they also organize who will be saying
the opening karakia and the closing
blessing and making sure all the
information around event planning and
project order organising as com is
communicated
they will be called on to do lots of
promotional work moving to fords as well
the next group is the events group which
is run by sam copeland who organises any
upcoming events that the youth council
is involved in
as a council we each have the
opportunity to do a deer like we are
wearing pajamas to school or doing the
ice bucket challenge which in this
weather is a real challenge
to fundraise money so far i believe
three of us have done a challenge and
i'm still waiting for my embarrassing
challenge from mark in return but with
her helping me complete my gold duke
event earlier this year
we also encourage you to check out the
oldest boy bandit the oldest boy band in
the world's
rendition of
brown eyed girl on video thank you to
steve perry brian griffiths russell
patterson and mark for getting in the
fundraising for getting the fundraising
ball rolling although we have watched it
and mark was terrible
all the funds that we recently raised
are going to pink shirt day fund which
is all about anti-bullying and we have
raised 150 so far for this great cause
the money raised
after that will go towards providing
opportunities and purchasing equipment
for people with disabilities in gore
this will become a long-term plan for
future youth councils to come
and the last
group is the project group which i
manage
the projects group has been very busy
this year as they have decided to help
revamp the skate park as you might have
seen late last year the youth council
went to the old gore high school on
richmond street and filled in potholes
and collected rubbish as we saw there
was a serious issue and we with the help
of nick grant and mark decided to do
something about it
the same day we also went to the skate
park as we saw a facebook post from a
former youth councillor who had taken a
photo of the rubbish at the skate park
and said that he had tried to fix it
when he was on the council
i saw that and thought that as a as
current youth councillors we should do
something about it so we did
we went and collected all the rubbish at
the skate park which was a very
difficult job especially trying to grab
the rubbish between the fence and the
concrete where we had to use rakes to
fish it out
as the projects group they helped to
come up with a way of avoiding this
problem altogether
after having a meeting with the parks
and rec manager keith mcbride they
concluded to move the bins to a more
accessible place to help encourage more
people to use the bins
keith also mentioned removing the fence
altogether to completely avoid rubbish
getting stuck getting stuck there which
is a plausible fix
we are also looking at the broken thing
offence which can
and what we can do about it
the youth council were also contacted
about the possibility of creating a
frisbee golf course in hamilton park
the one in doleman park is quite a
distance to travel out of or to play
so we are going to explore this
opportunity
charlotte wright and i also attended the
artera youth declaration conference
charlotte online and i in person at the
federator farmers building back in may
the antero youth declaration forum is a
report that is submitted to parliament
containing information from the from you
from the youth across the country
regarding issues facing youth today and
ideas on how to improve these things
my workshop was extremely interesting as
we did a workshop based on communication
as they believed that helping us to be
better communicators in general is a
very important life skill to learn
then we had freedom of choice
essentially to discuss what we wanted
for the rest of the workshop and we
chose education
the purpose of the workshop was for us
to have conversations about what we find
unfair or feel disadvantaged etc and
ideas we think would help to resolve
these issues
overall the whole workshop was extremely
eye-opening and very successful and i
believe charlotte had a similar
experience on her four-day online course
just yesterday we also started talking
about the youth awards and got the ball
rolling with that so hopefully after two
years we will be able to finally put on
the youth orders again which will be an
awesome celebration for the youth in goa
and all around the gore district once
again
thank you thank you
thank you um olivia and sophie that's
fantastic it's um
certainly a busy organisation to be part
of for the sound of things um
and i know i hear
you say that mark has all sorts of
activities to embarrass you i hope
you're embarrassing him along the way
and just on that note mark is there
anything you want to add to what the
girls have said
to say that we've today a very young
youth council this year that ever
reflects the diversity of the community
as well
um
yeah
so counselors um any comments or
questions you might have of uh olivia
and sophie
doug
thank you your worship um
ladies i've been sitting
around this table for 10 years
and this that was the best youth report
council report i've ever seen
it was
it was
thorough
it was precise it was really well done
it was interesting you kept us
captivated the whole time
i have seen previous
reports and people with their head down
or whatever you guys did a really good
job
and
i'm really quite
confident in
the ability for you to lead these
younger ones coming through and no well
done thank you very much
any other comments counselors have
if not look
thank you for the good work you've done
and i'm really enthusiastic and excited
about what the future might look like
and it'll be great to get the youth
awards back on the on the calendar so
keep up the good work thank you thank
you very much and thank you mark
right we've um i think that's brought us
to the end of the open session of
council
so
we'll
move into
committee for some
items that need to be discussed
behind closed doors so i'll
move that the public best